potential if it's the other way around
um maybe maybe magnus didn't give the
chance maybe he resigned i didn't
actually see how the game actually ended
he might resign before a draw offer to
come through just not given the
opportunity to put any mental questions
there you know that could have possibly
happened but it was a it was a real
dynamic end to the game uh very
unsurprising can magnus now bounce back
with the black pieces yeah that is the
issue i mean on the subject i just
wanted to give my thoughts i just think
it's part and parcel of internet chess
and the players uh developing black
establishing a triangle formation with
his pawns and uh you know i have to say
i have to read you a tweet from casey
grovesknows who actually says
magnus was late fell asleep at the board
one blunder then mouse slip no draw
offer no way yeah so i mean
many people are saying no absolutely not
yeah i understand i mean uh i mean if
he'd have played one f3 no way would he
have got a draw offer you know and he
did turn up late um to the game you
could argue that's that's not entirely
correct um but okay we're into the
second game now so uh magnus needs to
prove something now yeah magnus himself
i don't think he would want that
generosity from his opponent he wants to
yeah he wants things to be decided on
the board anyway so okay a few moves
into the opening nothing too special has
happened um it did start out as the
queen's gambit but as you micah
mentioned black has kind of established
this triangle formation with his pawns
black's pawns in the center uh making
that triangle and it's just rock solid
we did see a trade of dark squared
bishops meanwhile magnus back to taking
a power nap potentially and uh
there we go
definitely not full of energy even after
that first game
and uh okay magnus has a healthy
position he's just castled as king as
black
white needs to develop his pieces but
this is the type of position you would
you will need energy later on as black
just to equalize let alone try to win
this game
uh it's very much white with a small
space advantage the better pawn
structure
so okay magnus perking up there again
opening his eyes and maybe ready to move
i'm expecting the black okay rook or
knight to come to the center black's
pieces over there they just need to
i keep saying wake up but i can't say
that anymore they just need to join the
action they need to join the game
and uh yeah white's bishop or queen now
most likely to move
now liam with the white pieces in this
game getting a win in that first game a
little bit surprisingly after that mouse
slip um
with the black pieces do you think he's
his
mentality in this game is to just go for
another win to go two points up to the
world champion
i mean i i think he's just gonna play
with you know he doesn't need to go
crazy because it's the world champion i
mean if he loses this game you know that
first game is irrelevant so a draw good
result really uh he gets a bit closer to
the finishing line and that's seven and
a half thousand dollars which is pretty
tasty oh yeah um so just play the
position
don't take too many risks and see what
kind of mood magnus is in as well
because you know it is over to him now
he's got he's really got to prove it
he's going to be very upset after after
losing that game um so maybe give him
the opportunity to to blunder yeah and
we saw time and again last season on the
tour that the kind of professional
approach once you take the lead no
matter what the color is to just
kind of play safety first and not
necessarily meaning you're playing for
the draw but just kind of playing
sensible chess sensible dress and as
simon says wait for your opponent to do
something wait for them because they are
behind to kind of take the risks and
then you
and then you can maybe take your chances
if they do come but yeah especially with
white here what liam's doing is just
really solid really sound he's put his
pieces on good squares
and black is the one with this last porn
trade and now with this move black is
the one trying to equalize trying to
trade off pawns in the center to make
things symmetrical and uh yeah liam's
just done a very sensible job here he's
castled as king as well now so white is
ahead in development and uh after this
porn trade white will take back with his
knight most likely he doesn't want an
isolated pawn in the center and still a
move or two before black gets organized
and uh a nice move there by magnus just
getting ready to bring his knight out to
challenge white's knight in the center
of the board
it's very balanced in general but
zero risk at all for liam right now yeah
and that's what he kind of wants you
know i totally agree with you both um
i mean we've seen it time and time again
you know as chess players we love
patterns and we saw it in the charity
cup and the air things masters players
couldn't actually recover when they were
one point down because the opponents
always kind of locked the position up
and they played very solidly and
i mean i can even think
of uh the air things masters um the
match between liam and magnus i mean
magnus won the game and liam no can make
no headway yeah i think one of the
biggest improvements i i probably had
was when i was young and i was looking
at the games of grand masters in english
tournaments and you could note these
older grandmasters they'd often win
games by doing nothing and that sounds
like a very strange thing but they
they'd wait until their opponent make
the mistake and they wouldn't even try
to do many things they'd just sit there
they would play very risk-free they
wouldn't try to attack because it
weakened their position and they just
wait and wait and wait and the pressure
will build in these match situations on
magnus because at some point he has to
win so he has to take a risk so i think
that is certainly the right approach
yeah old manchester simon that's exactly
what i try to do nowadays i try to do
nothing and just wait for my opponent to
come at me you do nothing very well yeah
you do it very very well so it's a
decent strategy it does work you know i
had the grand master do that to me once
he just literally shuffled the pieces
and it was a bit of a
mind kind of
one
bad word came out but it was it was
really mind-boggling because every time
i was like why is he playing like this
and i ended up burning time on the clock
and in the end i was the one that lost
patience and i did something and of
course
backfired on me big time yeah and
there's this famous example right of one
of the greatest strategic players one of
the greatest positional players of all
time off anderson and he just did
nothing for 15 20 moves
ah uh actually it was against all
vanderson where uh his opponent uh was
it mike bassman did basketball yeah for
20 moves yeah yeah and then um and yeah
eventually off just didn't it just got
frustrated and lashed out and that was
at the hastings tournament i think and
uh basman's one of the real mavericks of
english chess and the saint george is
actually one of his openings really uh
him and tony miles so it's quite
appropriate to to mention him and uh i
also remember that was a quiz question
at the reykjavik pub quiz and they
showed a position and magnus guessed the
two players guess the year
yes and it was a bizarre yeah yeah he
did he guessed everything which is uh
shows his incredible memory um you know
impossible question to get the weird
position which two players which year
and he guessed mike basically
one of the legends of british chess but
maybe not so well known outside of it
and magnus of course knew the answer no
one else did just magnus did so it was
yeah it was crazy yeah so if i ever
write a book called the art of doing
nothing then that that game will feature
maybe this one as well
and in this game there have been a few
developments but nothing too special
it's actually very reminiscent of the
early stages of the previous game
between these two earlier today at least
the opening stage it was basically
identical pawn structure it's completely
symmetrical right now and uh yeah just
pieces flying off the board bishops have
been traded a set of rooks have also
left the board now black has lined up
his queen and rook against the white
bishop i'm expecting that bishop to be
defended by weights rook there we go
and finally a threat actually against
the black queen white bishop was
threatening to jump out the way with a
check hit the black king and then the
black queen would have been under fire
from white's rook so you never want your
queen opposite your opponent's rooks
that's why magnus stepped back and look
at this liam he's actually barely paused
magnus actually with more time than he
started with but both players just
trading off all the pieces
the hoover has come out and uh yeah all
the rooks have come off a set of bishops
it looks like liam just very happy to
consolidate his extra point from earlier
today yeah i think heading towards the
draw yeah it certainly looks that way i
mean it's always a bit dangerous to do
that i find but uh
when when you're this caliber of player
they they can do that in these positions
i mean there's no weakness
and again go back to wolf anderson one
of the most interesting things he said
to me um i was playing the same team as
him and uh i said well i always try to
play the best move in the position and
he said um i don't i was like you're one
of the one you're one of the best
players of all time what do you mean he
goes i just try to play a move that
doesn't make a mistake
and uh i thought oh hello
you know it's a totally different way of
looking at the game you know rather than
trying to find the best move he tried to
play moves that didn't make any
weaknesses and that was his style and i
found that really interesting as
approach to the game of chess so yeah i
have to say on that subject you know i
was actually on the same team assignment
and off anderson and it was so wonderful
to be
like um watching these two players who
completely different styles simon let's
say he's a quite optimistic attacker
life's coming forward very very
dangerous and ulf is very much safety
first and if he gets a little niggle and
and uh you know we would kind of get
together after the team finished the
games and then we would kind of analyze
we would play chess and and they would
just completely disagree
it was like the meeting of mines that
was that was the most wonderful thing i
remember a great incident from that
because off really is one of the top um
players scandinavian players of all time
he's a legend and uh we i i sacrificed
my queen for some dodgy compensation in
some game we looked at the game
afterwards with some wine and off
he could just calculate so well he saw
all the tactics he saw them much quicker
than me and he's just pointing out all
these ideas and i thought well hang on a
minute he's never playing like this but
he he could play like that that was the
point and he was uh quite a unique and
very nice brilliant player so yeah wow
that's the thing actually it's a myth
that positional players don't calculate
or they don't do tactics right but they
use their calculation skills and use
their tactics to prevent their
opponent's ideas and uh yeah it's a bit
like
another individual sport tennis uh simon
would be the guy who's going for a
winner with every shot trying to uh
trying to win the point immediately ulf
would just be trying to get the ball
back into play just wait for the
opponent to hit it out
that's an interesting uh yeah it's a
very nice analogy but that's one of the
beautiful things about chess i mean not
much as i have to say happening in the
game here we'll come to a minute but one
of the beautiful things about chess is
you can put your personality onto the
game
and that shows at the higher level you
get and i think that's a really
beautiful uh thing about the game you
can sort of uh see that in the moves
that are played often by players
yeah and uh the reason we haven't been
talking too much about the moves is
because not too much has happened queens
have been traded off it's just an end
game now with bishops and knights but
it's still
perfectly symmetrical pawn structure
black can block up
either side of the board later on if he
wants to and
that's minimal minimal hope for either
side to win this game it's simply
impossible to create a past pawn and if
you can't create a past pawn push
forward promote make a new queen then no
real chance of winning this one
both kings of centralized and yeah it's
just very much headed towards the draw
and that is good news for liam he won
the first game today let's take a look
at the results in all the matches in the
first games of today so liam lie is up
by one point against magnus carlsen
remember
a total of four rapid games to decide
each match juden von forest he got a win
against eric hanson and is up by one
point pragnanda he's just having such a
good start to the tournament he won his
match yesterday and he won the first
game today against chakriyad mamadiarov
duda and geary they played a draw in the
first game and all the matches
are now ongoing with game
two and i guess by the tone of your
voice that you're maybe expecting this
one to fizzle out into a draw yeah i
mean the game is in really calm waters
at the minute and i don't expect it to
last
too much longer and it will be settled
peacefully and i think it's perfect time
to show your selfie from dmitry
stanislav who is watching the show from
traditional cyprus which is a lovely
island with amazing nature and weather
we can see it yeah but we're also having
good weather and also as well so
normally i'm quite jealous but here
you know it's well it's great to be
watching in beautiful
nature what is the weather like in
bergen now where you live it's actually
not bad wow
yeah it's been really really sunny and i
have to say about bergen it's norway
second city and usually the weather is
just rainy and it's horrible and grey
but when it's when it's a beautiful
weather you feel like you're living in
paradise
it's a stunning place for those few
minutes every year when the sun is
shining in bergen
the rivalry coming through
oslo
all right we do have a few moves on the
board and this rivalry is it fizzling
out david yes
if you look at the pawn structure now
it's pretty much as blocked as it can be
in the center of the board i slightly
prefer magnus's position if i had to
choose just because uh white's pawning
in the middle of the board slightly
blocks in his bishop but it's
i mean it's not really a significant
factor right now we could see
white's knight come and give the black
king a check white could push some pawns
on either side of the board but still no
way to imbalance things and just look at
the clock times for both players they've
barely paused and that means that they
both know what's about to happen a draw
is imminent here we go it's a check
black's king has to be slightly careful
where it goes maybe but uh once it finds
a safe square
i'm expecting the players to play a few
more quick moves maybe trade another set
of pieces off and then just repeat the
position to make a draw i'm not sure
whether they can offer uh offer draws or
whether they will offer draws normally
that's a sign of pride you don't want to
be the one showing weakness and clicking
the draw offer button uh but
yeah sister this time in the arena they
can actually just look at each other and
go hey
draw yeah that's kind of unusual i wink
at each other
can it be like a peace sign or something
yeah actually uh in over-the-board chess
especially when i was young when i was
playing people who we didn't share
common language with the common sign to
offer a draw is kind of like that yeah
oh yeah and then the opponent will nod
well sometimes you can even offer a draw
just by a smile and i remember playing a
grand master friend and we just like
looked at each other and we just kind of
laughed and went you know and then
started analyzing the game and it but it
kind of like it didn't occur to us until
a few days later you know we actually
hadn't offered a draw we just kind of
agreed yeah but could it sometimes
happen that it's some confusion and
i remember as a russian grandmaster and
he always played at hastings and he just
had a permanent smile
and it was really weird
like the joker and you look at him
you're like why is he smiling
what have i done
oh my god it looks like yeah i don't
know if you know the guy but he's i
won't mention his name but it was really
disturbing
a russian grandmaster yeah yeah he just
had a permanent smile i was like
why why you just you're just like you
know five hours smile oh wow
doesn't really love stress that is yeah
i suppose so yeah mental game
yeah yeah
all right well magnus has been playing
the mental game in uh well so far in
this tournament yesterday playing an old
opening to put the young christophe
dudoff today arriving a little bit late
falling asleep
but in this one it's calming down magnus
with the black pieces that drew here
must be sensible and then going all out
for the win in game three yeah the
position we see on the board right now
it's very much the type of position
where you could imagine a player falling
asleep to be honest uh so yeah it's
it's strange that magnus fell asleep
earlier when it was maybe the start of a
more exciting game now it's just really
not too much happening and body language
if you look at the two players liam i
mean he's so stoic right just never
breaks pose never seems to panic even in
the last game where for a moment or two
he was maybe in a bit of trouble
never really breaking sweat magnus much
more expressive magnus at least looks
fresher than he did maybe an hour or two
ago
and uh
yeah okay pushing a pawn here
not changing the nature of the position
at all really
and uh yeah black might push a pawn
black can just wait with the bishop
so we will follow this game until it has
uh finished because we want to follow
the players out to the lounge to see if
they give some reactions to zlatan and
after that we're gonna
sorry jump into another game of course
in this round yeah
and whilst the players are just moving
their pieces around i'd like to ask both
you
and
david a question from luffy who says
if you had to play
e4 or d4 which is moving the king's pawn
to squares forward or the queen's pawn
two squares forward for one year
which one would you pick
well i mean uh
eva's he was cool with me um i mean
would you just roll the dice
just rather dice i mean they're both
great moves i mean i i think in general
you should generally stick to the same
opening when you're learning but as you
get better you can
sort of adapt to other openings to
increase your crucial knowledge
especially nowadays how chess has
developed when we were young you should
stick to the same opening play the same
ideas but with the information available
now it's much quicker to learn things i
mean maybe for me i'd have a change and
play the kingsborn for a year because i
normally do
the the other pawn just to you know mix
it up a little bit
okay and now i'm going to say the exact
opposite i normally well at least when i
was younger i used to play e4 but i'll
say d4 just to mix things up a bit and
it's funny you mentioned rolling the
dice as well because when i played a
recent tournament i literally couldn't
decide my first move so i rolled the
dice and it came up one d4 so i had to
play d4 the whole match was was there
free on the dice f3 wasn't on the dust
only sensible moves
luckily there was only space for six
options on the
uh dice i played d4 and the match went
pretty well so yeah i've actually tried
some dice chests and just played around
with some different rules where you you
know you play a move you have to roll
the dice to see what piece you're moving
some stupid variants but um yeah nothing
beats traditional chess though yeah no
we're talking about dice chess you know
it's a good one actually um to play when
you're playing against the beginner
because you just roll you roll the dice
and you know it tells you what piece you
have to move sometimes it's uh quite
interesting interesting yeah
okay and meanwhile a couple more moves
so actually liam going for maybe a more
ambitious option than i thought he would
just pushing a pawn forward harry the h
pawn may be a potential winner of this
game if you look at all the pawns that
pawn that has just moved is the most far
advanced pawn on the whole board
and therefore the pawn actually in front
of it if you look at black's h-pawn it's
potentially a weakness if you could
imagine white's knight jumping and
trying to grab it later on then white's
h pawn will run through a very quick
pass pawn there the problem for white is
that the knight no matter where it jumps
into into black's half of the board it
will get eliminated by black's bishop uh
so if you look at actually all of the
minor pieces the bishops and knights
white's bishop is controlled by the
black knight and vice versa and also
white's knight is
completely controlled by the black
bishop meanwhile magnus pushing this a
pawn forward as she saw on his computer
screen just a few minutes ago he was
itching to play this move earlier but he
delayed it and he changed his mind a
couple of times now he has pushed this
pawn forward
it's just going to completely lock up
the position i think uh in the next few
moves i think the only way either side
is going to win this position is by a
big blunder you know
yeah yeah
and this move now is locking it up more
slightly dangerous putting your pawns on
the same color square as your opponent's
bishop that's the only thing you've had
to be a little bit careful of but you
can see there i think again by by
magnus's face really that he knows this
this is this is a draw and
neither sides i mean if they blunder
here it'll be it'd be pretty amazing
really yeah so
it's hard to imagine uh anything
too drastic happening now
and yeah as you mentioned magnus's face
was like
yeah come on let's uh yeah let's get out
of here let's take a break
and uh it's actually interesting who
this will favor more uh i mean the
quicker game maybe liam wants to keep
magnus at the board for longer maybe he
knows magnus is a bit tired maybe he'll
just keep the game going and going and
going and not click that draw button
anytime soon magnus clearly looks like
he wants to get out of there play that
mental game right back at magnus
basically exactly that would show some
uh i'm not going to say that
it's going to show something
i've done it before
[Laughter]
why not just keep your opponent at the
board it gives them less time to prepare
the openings and magnus has white in the
next game maybe give him less time to
prepare yeah it makes a lot of sense oh
okay it's gonna be a little bit
interesting to see now william
try to uh you know play on here
commentator's curse he'll probably click
uh draw off a button any anytime soon
but uh it's just a different strategy um
liam is quite a respectful guy in
general he'll probably just think okay
let's just make the draw
totally dead now isn't it now now
they've locked the queen side as well
they've locked up there's no pawn breaks
i mean if you if you're going to win a
position like this you have to really
have i think it's going to come yeah
yeah it's going to come free white is
just going to shuffle the king backwards
and forwards black is going to do the
same
all of the minor pieces are on their
perfect squares so the kings are the
only ones that can really do anything
that's when magnus wakes up of course
but you know
magnus does win games sometimes but he's
not going to win this one i thought he's
had his head oh he's gone he's got it
he's gone for something okay wow risky
move therefore wow
that's and liam does have a reaction
yeah he didn't i mean this is avoiding a
draw
because he could have really moved his
king back and they could have mirrored
each other done a three-fold uh
repetition taking a draw but he's
actually trying
something
looks really risky um probably doesn't
change anything but still well how could
liam take advantage of this is there
anything you're seeing well the first
thing here to look at is actually
capturing the bishop right yeah
definitely
yep he could take that bishop in two
ways white could capture it with his own
bishop or with the knight and either way
eventually black's pawn structure would
have to change
black would have to recapture with this
pawn on the next move or the move after
and uh rather than this kind of complete
blocked up symmetry that we see suddenly
the pawn structure will change and
that's why we said there's risk involved
black will end up he's going to end up
with an isolated pawn but the reason
it's still a draw is because any time
the white king comes forward the black
king will uh actually come forward
itself and block it off we're just going
to see a dance of the kings now
still nothing to be done magnus
calculated it it looks super risky but
that's just a standoff it's almost uh
yeah i mean it's just nothing to do
rumble with the kings here yeah and
we're going to see the position repeat
yeah they're going to dance a little bit
more and there we go it is a draw all
right eventually a draw between them in
game two that means liam lee after two
games is still in the lead in the match
he won the first game magnus